Herkese
merhaba arkadaşlar beni keyfine düşkün
bir zaman öğretmenim bugün Borcam Çok
keyifli bunun için Hepinize çok teşekkür
ediyorum Umut daha demeci ve keyifli bir
ortam
bu birazcık kendine bahsettik olursa
Çukurova'da doğdum
babaannemin yönettiği çiftlikte doğdu
babam yardım ederdi babamın paydaşları
diyeyim bizim tabirde işte
Yaşar Kemal birbirleriyle nasıl
ulaştıklarını hatırlıyorum Yatılı Bölge
okulundan takip emmim emrediyorum Şu
anda çocuklar geliyor bizim oraya eğitim
için falan
üniversiteden öğrencilerde geliyor kadın
çiftçiliğin yapıldığı Bir çiftlikte
doğdu o çok acı krovat sıcaktır bir
yaylaları sevenlerdeniz
Yayla kültürümüz var
Bir de şu anda Hani neden bahsedeceğim
Nereye geleceğim bunar köye geleceğim
narköy gibi köy kurduk kendimize bütün
bu altyapıdaki atılan adımlar
Bir de oraya getirme var yani yapmasak
için dediğim halde
kadın Çiftliği nedir Savaş zamanlarında
ip kadınlar Çiftlik yapar hareli ayağı
tutan genç kalmamıştır çok yaşlılar
vardır maniler vardır Bu ve kadının
derdi kaç lira kaç para değildir orada
da Muğla kültür yapmaz bunu
ailesine o batını köyünü doyurmak ister
cephedeki çocuğumu doyurmak ister
ve
dolayısıyla sağ
elinin altına bir bahçe olsun ister gece
gündüz 56 bahçeleri bizim gibi çocuklar
da peşinde dolanırlar onları ben de
yapayım yapabilir miyim ben deneyebilir
miyim bu olabilir mi bu olabilir mi
Tamam tamam uyumunun bu resimden dene
bakalım yarın Başka nereyi denemek
isteyeceksin şimdi Bunun kıymetini
anlıyorum ne kadar değerli olduğunu o
denemeye tareti mi Beni merak edip
sorduğumuzda benim aklım bu kadar neldi
Ben anlattım Bunu git filana da
Dora günümüzde Avşarlar yürükler bugün
sana gelen göçmenler gerek bir arada
yaşardık O ortak Güldür'de çok güzeldi
mezar Hiç bilmediğim bir şey Biz
saçlarda pişirip ben çevireceğim
açacağım devamlı öyle şey ben söylerdim
ama
göçmende teyzelerin amcaların ablaların
yanına gittiğim zaman Ağa onların başka
türlü fırını var şimdi o fırından Nar
Köyde de var ee mesajda yapıp emonda
yapıyor biliyorum ortak kültürlerde çok
kıymetli
geceleri yaylaya gidinceye kadar sıcak
olur Okul kapanmadan yaylaya gidilmez
zaten hani köyde kalanlar var münavebeli
olur bir kayma deriz çardaklarda
yatardık ki binlikler kurulurdu ve
Düşler kurardık düş kurma hiç
yadırganan bir şey değildi
Oy kuzum benim düşüne ne öyle dönerlerdi
ay sonra öyle bir zaman geldi ki çok
hayal bir etsin bu olmaz şu olur A ama
biz düş kurmaktan vazgeçmedik Hatta
narköy de mutlu bir hikaye anlatmıştım
yerleşme zorlandığımız zaman onun
altında Uzunca bir hikaye var
zorlandığımız geç geldiğimiz zaman bizim
Nineler dedeler
evlenir üstü çatı kapalı açık demişler
Ya bilgi Yıldızlara bakmadan uyuyamayız
uyuyamayız açılmış Bizler de bakarak düş
kurardık anatomide bunun bir karşılığı
var sonradan öğrendim meraklı
çocuklardık ailemiz Doğa bir dizi doğal
olmakta olmasıydı babam rahmetli
teknolojiye meraklıydı İki Dünya Savaşı
sırasında ilk Evet şimdi at geriye gidi
yetti
baca örgüt öğretilmez ehliyet dağılmış
onun şoförlüğü ne yapmış çok çok
okunurdu çok yoğun olur Dua kitap
okumayı severdik büyük Bom'un enteresan
kitapları bakın yıllar oldu hala
çocukken onun bazı kitapları işte Arapça
Farsça Fransızca bilirdi bir Doğa
büyükbaba ben bu dili öğreninceye kadar
söylemen gerek söylemen gerek diye
Boğazım çıkardık ve söylenirdi O ne ya
Bıktım senin merakımdan dediklerini
duymadım ve merak benim normalim oldu
ailenin diğer renklerine de bakıyorum
veya köyümüzden çıkıyor çıkanlara da
epey farklı şeyler yapanlar var icat
çıkar acılarla
Dolayısıyla
düş kurmak Dediğimden bu sonra
E
tabi Atatürk'ün gördük İstikbal
göklerdedir diyorlar ve gün kafamda
gitti çocuklara bak koş geçiyor diyoruz
geçiyor diyoruz ağlayan çocuk gülmeye
başlıyor Hatta bir gün yeğenim de
yaşadım odan burada üç dört yaşındaydı
Benim oğlumun adı noda Devleti odam çok
sevince kendininkini de odan adını koydu
Ondan sonra
ara çok dinlerdim falan o zaman kim
dedim avizeyi Annen yeni mi aldı dedi
Yok yok evde görmedin mi daha önce dedi
baktı baktı ona döndü Biraz önce ben çok
kızgınım kızgınım geriye gitti dedi
o lazım mıydı o zaman dedim lazım değil
ama birşey yaptım Sen dedi O ne olduğunu
bana anlatacaksın dedi
belki dedim başımı yukarı kaldırıp bana
kızgın suratı yapar mısın dedim Bize
deneyimiz der temiz
Biz başımızı yukarı kaldırdığımızda Bu
da muhakkak Gülümser'in kızgın surat
mümkün değil ve imamın bir dene
faydasına ne faydası var o Eğer bu rakip
oluyorlar çözüm odaklı oluyorlar yere
bakarak
O biraz zor olmuş aynı yere iç
bakmayalım demiyorum başımızı gökyüzüne
kaldırdığımızda geçmişini bilir iza'nın
farkında oluruz geleceği Korkular ve
günüm deyince oynayan katlar şurada bir
yere aydınlatır Yabancılarla Point
diyorlar buna o
aydınlanmayla çözüm üretmeye başlarız
Hatta bazen konuşulan kelimelerden
uzakta bir bile olsa yalnız olmasa bile
anlayabilirsiniz umutsuzluğa düştüğünü
Ben bazen bazı öğrencilerim onu demiştim
vardır büyüklerle de çok çalışma yaptım
ama ya Bir Pencerenin önüne gidip
gökyüzüne baktı mı Orada hava nasıl
o İçimizdeki Çocuk bir yere gitmedi onu
dinle yapacağım yere baktım Nereden
bildin Sen
anatomi bileceğiz bunun lami cimi yok
anatomi bu dünyada kullandığımız
malzememiz bu an çocuk kendi öyle görmüş
olmak farkında olmayı getiriyor denemede
yeterdi merak geçici düş kuruculuk
düşlerin hoş görünür birşey oldu Üstüne
de Adamı gördüm İstikbal göklerde derken
yükler dedim Derken sadece havacılıktan
bahsetmiyor dum gökyüzüne bakın geleceği
Tatar Lion vizyonel olun bakın ne kadar
hızlı değişimler oluyor her birini tek
kendim döndü yaratılmadık mı Bana göre
insan da bir tohumdur Hani doğada her
bir gerçek doğum çok önemsiyorum
arkadaşımın anladığı Edirne uğraşan
arkadaşımdan değil gibi biz onların
ayarını buldum yanıma gelme değil
oynanmış doğuma döndürmek yemek yendi
olmalarına ne fırsat bize bu fırsatlar
tanındığı için
biz bu kadar yol tak edebildik
ve yıllar geçti bu
okumaya meraklı
bir aileden gidip Doğa doğa ile ilgili
anlatmak istediklerim var
ve doğaya yakın olup benim 2 perde
olduğu için daha sonra 72 yılında
öğretmen oldum ben Ama bu arada bir
şeyler oldu Çok şey değişti neler
değişti bizim köyümüzde pamuk ekili
çoğunlukla karpuz Adana karpuz deyince
benim benim gelir akla Adana Ceyhan
gösteri a işte onun içine Karpuzlar
atardı başka şeyler atardım babaannem
bir yandan da burada kuş ağacı olsun
derdik onu çok severdim Benim de derdik
biz 3. çocuklar giderdi komutlar
toplanırken amcıklar toplanırken üças
toplanırdı dördüncü ağzı şey toplaması o
tarlanın sahibi
oraya işçilik için gelenler
bu çünkü aradılar giymiş binlerce dönemi
yeşil için gelenler tarlası olmayanlar
okumaya gidecek gençler onlar dört beş
altı toplardı ve çıt çıt fabrikasında
gidecekti
takipemi mi
traktör götürür der ki pamuğu geri
istiyorsun öğretmeni istiyorsun ona göre
gittiniz Bakın bu toz geldik önemi Bugün
dudeli günümü dön güzellik dönemi
kaybolduğu için yardımla yaşamıyoruz bir
yeniden gelebilmek için gayret ediyoruz
insan
ano yedi yaş altında gördükleri yaşanır
yaşadıkları
inanılmaz etkili oluyor oniki yaşına
kadar bir daha etkili oluyor Bunları hep
hayatımızı
ben o diğerleri gelişini görüp uyanmış
çocuklardan biriyim
ya hani böyle yardımlaşma vardı değiller
yoktu
o değiller girdiğinde çok sevindi doldum
izlerini tarlaya gitmedi yataktan
babaannem atmıyorum ama uçakla atılıyor
her taraf Değil Gönlüm balık tutmaya
gidemiyorsun tarlaya konuşamıyorsun onun
işte Oo bir çocuğun gözünden işler
farklı görünüyor Ben öğretmenlik
hayatımda şimdi aklım karışık olmayıp
çocuklara danışalım
dümdüz gündüz derdimi söyledim kafam
karışık dedim
bana yardım eder misin dedim o kadar
güzel fikirler olur ki onlar kendileri
iken evden yeni gelmişken diyorum ben
Elif kirlenmeye uğramamış gel
söyleyeceğim Şu yıllar geçti Neyse
öğretmenlik hayatımda
ve o anlatılan Ancın Avdan başka bir şey
düşünüyorum yani
çocukları neredeyse metal aştığı bir
dönemler O çok canımı yaktı benim göre
öğretmenim var da bir sürü yaptığım
işler var kendime göre gücümün yettiği
kadar
bir ve bir gün okul bahçesinde bir çocuk
düştü bizi Parçalandım bana neler
gerekli herkese çıkmıyor
e okul tercih sınav kazanmak için değil
kitap okuyacaksın sosyal eşeksin
konuşacaktım arkadaşlık öğreneceksin
Bütün bunlar var
var ama hızla kayboluyor
Bu
bir düşük gizli parçaladım insanlar ne
zaman bir girişim yapar biliyor musunuz
daha önce oğluma yuva bulamadığımda eşim
orada bir arka vardı onu tadı bir açtım
biliyorum öğretmenliğe devam ederken bir
yandan da hani insanların değerleri
zarar gördüğünde bir giriş etmesi
geliyor işte o gün o gün
Ben dedim ki çocuğu koşma hakkında
oynama hakkını elinden aldık
köprüyle kendini iyileştirme kabiliyeti
durdurduk Toprak bak yere Düşte ve her
tenis çıktı zaten Belki o kadar şimdi
etti koşmayacak
1 2 3 Çünkü o gerilim birikiyor Üstelik
daha da iyi öğrenilmiyor durumda da
hareket ihtiyaçları var o ara Yetimin
elinden aldık eğlenme hakkını
Arkadaşlığı dostluğu elinden aldık
bu çok büyük Adalet Benim üç tane temel
değilim var arkadaşlarım Adalet 1 ve
adalet bir tek sevgimi özgürlük bunları
da doğru tanımlamak çok önemli
değişiklikle Adalet aynı değil sol
kapıda adaletli açılıyor iftara ile olun
ister işyeri olur ne olur senin oğlum bu
çok önemli
Dolayısıyla o gün bir diş kuruldu hala
bunu bugün dokunmayacağım Ama şu kağıtta
bugün bana doğum günü bir defter
vermişti bir eğitim ve organik tarım
Çiftliği kuracağım doğanın içinde olacak
şu olacak bu olacak bak EGO sistemle
uyumlu olacak geldiğimiz kültürün
altında bu var zaten
biz yaylaya gittiğimiz zaman
babamın evi yapacak durum olmasına
rağmen yapmazdı Çardak gibi yerler
yapılırdı ya da Yörük Çadırı kuruldu
artist yine baktığımız yerde ot bitmiş
mi diye bakılırdı abone olup çocuk
etmesi toplanan
şimdi buna bakıyoruz suyu kirletir zaten
olmaz abi doğada öğrenecek çok şey vardı
Keşke vaktimiz olsa bir gün konuşuyoruz
el Arkasına dönen insan olmayıda
Anneannem öğretti Ama adam diyorum ki
benim Cadılar büyüktür diyorum ve biz
bugün narköy bu düşle kuruldu ve
ekosistem prensipleri birdir bizde bir
ya ondan sonra
ama Eko türlü diagro turizm
eğitim turizmi hepsi bir arada yapılıyor
çevreden arkadaşlarla çalışıyoruz tosyal
ekonomidir dön güzel ekonomidir bir aynı
zamanda tatlı Çiftliği
17 bine yakın bütün dünyadan gönüllüler
ladık bunu da barışa çok büyük katkısı
oldu önyargıların yıkılmasına çok büyük
katkısı oldu ve oradaki gençlerimiz
insanlarımızın okuma oranı artık okuyup
köye dönme oranı da arttı üretim arttı
bu anlamlarda Elimizden geleni yapmaya
çalışıyoruz
ekip demli iletişim hepinize lazım bakın
burada bile bu muhteşem adlı çeşitlik
oluştu değilmi bir ekosistem oluştu Biz
doğadaki ekosistemi anladığımızda kendi
yakın sistemimizde şimdi küçük
çocuklarla konuşurken Duygu bana göre
diye ben onu yapma
ailem bu okulun böyle olacak gibi
muhabbetler yapıyorlar Dolayısıyla
Türkiye'de bir ilk iz derdimizi
anlatmamız biraz uzun sürdü ilk olduğu
için bu organik tarım yapıyorum ve
Boncuğum l e şunu söylemek isterim daha
bir gün belgesel çek yani
delikanlılardan Birisi pek çok de
belgesel çekildi başka şeyler oldu bana
dedi ki Hocam doğum ne gittim için dedi
tohum benim bütün o çocukluğumdaki
meraklar düş burmalar denemeler
arkadaşlıklar tarlaya koşmalar icat
çıkarmalar hepsinin temsil ediyordu o an
farkettim hiç düşünmeden deli gibi
topladım ektim bu eğitimin lojistiğinde
de sağlıklı da çok önemli arkadaşlar
bu çünkü Denizli gıda gıda olmazsa olmaz
mı temizliği da
ve bunu yapmak mümkün pek çok okulda
yapıyoruz Birçok yerde yapıyoruz
çoğaltma istiyoruz Biz elimizdekini
kıymetini bilmesini istiyoruz be epeyce
çoğaldık yıllarca çok Yalnızlık çektim
ama bence çoğaldık çok şükür ve
okullarımıza da bahçe yapın Arkadaşlar
iyi gelir bir de zaman öğretmenleri
Köyde de yapardık şey gel dedi iyi gelir
davranış değişecek Deniz saptayıp çok
ciddi davranış değişiklikleri oluyor
kaynak farkındalığı oluyor süreç takibi
oluyor ekopsikoloji alanı kendini Yiğit
ediyorlar ve Kanton bankalarını
kuruyorlar kimseyle müdahale
ettiriyorlar
Evet bu da onları hem tatlı beklenmesi
Emre Özgür olmasını sağlıyor
Sen beni daha çok tutmayayım davetiniz
için tekrar teşekkür ediyorum
sağ ol